latest in afghanistan where the taliban
says it seized the country's second and
third largest cities kandahar and herrat
now unverified video to show you
circulating on social media purportedly
showing afghan security forces fleeing
kandahar just uh half an hour before the
taliban's announcement the u.s embassy
in kabul is urging all americans to
leave the country immediately going so
far as even to offer loans temporary
ones to those unable to afford plane
tickets home and to use the first
available commercial carriers they're
saying
meantime there's widespread speculation
indeed the capital kabul could fall to
the taliban within days here's the
situation at the moment i'll stand back
there's the key for you to take in the
militants controlled two-thirds of the
country you can see in red there um
government forces in the green and
what's contested is in yellow basically
the contested regions now currently the
islamists have taken hold of some
crucial strategically important
locations very near the capital
let's see the progress well the
taliban's ramped up its defensive
that's what's gone so far this year
since april particularly after us
president joe biden's announcement that
he was pulling american troops out at
the time the islamist group held less
than a fifth of the country's territory
but look at where it is more or less
today more than 50 more than half of it
with a taliban taking hold of multiple
provinces in a single day then u.s
troops are back to work in afghanistan
though with a slightly different mission
this time on the face of it they're
there they say to get u.s embassy staff
out of the country as the state
department says it's going to
dramatically reduce its diplomats in
kabul and although this may look like an
evacuation officials tried very hard to
strike an optimistic note
this is not abandonment this is not an
evacuation
this is not the wholesale withdrawal
what this is uh is a reduction in the
size of our civilian footprint this is a
drawdown of civilian
americans there are 3 000 u.s military
personnel
headed for afghanistan to secure what
it's calling a safe drawdown of american
civilian personnel basically u.s embassy
staff and others are going to be
escorted out of the country by the
military the military will be there to
make sure that they're not harmed in the
process now we do know at this point
that the taliban after receiving
receiving and seizing several provinces
in a single day is now inching closer to
the capital city of kabul but on tuesday
joe biden made clear that washington is
not going to step in to rescue kabul in
this situation
afghan leaders
have to come together
we lost
thousands lost death and injury
thousands of american personnel
they've got to fight for themselves now
the current taliban offensive began back
in april when joe biden announced that
he intended to withdraw all u.s forces
from the country by september 11th uh
now that gave questions gave rise to two
questions at this point uh you know it
what is really going on now will the usa
now that it's sent you know 3 000 more
troops to oversee the the you know the
withdrawal of u.s civilian personnel and
embassy staff will the usa continue to
have a role in the country
well when that question was presented to
the state department here's the response
this is not the reintroduction of
military forces
to pursue the mission that they were
pursuing prior to may 1. now september
11th is the deadline that joe biden set
for which the u.s forces will be
withdrawn from the country however u.s
officials continue to make clear that
despite pulling all u.s forces out of
the country they intend to still offer
support to the afghan government in the
face of the onslaught of the taliban now
how exactly this support will be offered
was something that john kirby
representing the pentagon refused to
clarify here's what happened when he was
asked about it does this mean the u.s
military withdrawal is not going to be
complete by august 31st again
what i said was we're aiming to
facilitate the reduction of these
civilian personnel by august 31st so
it's all lining up on the same timeline
i won't speculate about what the
footprint is going to look like post
august 31st because there's this
additional mission set of of helping
process special immigrants uh so we're
just gonna have to wait and see but the
drawdown itself
is still on track to be complete by
august thirty first that makes no sense
john i know i know we're talking about
three thousand troops i know what you're
saying lucas i'm saying of the of the
original footprint plans that's still
continuing but yes we are adding
additional troops for this specific and
narrow focus and you're hoping to get
them all out by the end of the month
i'm not going to speculate beyond august
31st now it's important to note the
united states has maintained a military
presence in afghanistan for over 18
years and during that time the country
has not become any more stable the role
of the drug lords and the poppy fields
has certainly expanded in the country
different terrorist groups and warlords
have battled for control the taliban
remained intact with different parts of
territory and such and now after 18
years of the united states not having
success when it came to the
stabilization of afghanistan we have the
united states set to leave the country
and despite the taliban marching ahead
and inching closer to kabul those plans
to withdraw from afghanistan seem to be
in full effect
yeah so with hostility showing no sign
of abating in afghanistan now the u.n is
warning that nearly 400 000 civilians
have had to leave their home since the
start of the year with a huge spike
since may
further the u.n saying the displaced
people are heading to kabul to flee the
taliban well how long will that last
given everything we just said
here are just some of the
heart-wrenching stories that refugees
have to tell
i have been displaced from telecom city
the taliban killed my son they took all
the belongings from my house and set
fire to them in front of me they punched
me in the mouth causing my teeth to fall
out they demanded my son and i told them
that he's a schoolteacher he recently
became a teacher and had not even
received his salary yet heavy clashes
broke out and we were taken hostage the
fighting went on for about six or seven
days we couldn't go outside or do
anything we managed to escape and now we
are displaced
yeah and where to go to those displaced
afghans seeking asylum may not be
welcome in europe either with the bloc
currently a big loggerhead
over what best to do with migrants and
those fleeing violence next and for you
rt's paula slayer delving into what
happened to europe's open door policy
the european union is split over what to
do with afghan refugees seeking asylum
in a letter to the european commission
several countries insisted they have the
right to forcibly deport those whose
cases have been rejected
they wrote that not to deport them would
motivate more refugees to flee to europe
we would like to highlight the urgent
need to perform returns both voluntary
and non-voluntary to afghanistan
stopping return sends the wrong signal
and is likely to motivate even more
afghan citizens to leave their home for
the eu
the situation in afghanistan is
deteriorating by the hour it comes as
the u.s and nato prepare to withdraw
their troops at the end of the month
after a decades-long war
the situation is so bad that the
netherlands germany and france have
decided to pause the deportations
at least for now
the situation in afghanistan is likely
to change and events for the coming
period are so uncertain that i have
decided to introduce a moratorium on
deportation decisions and departures
but greece austria belgium and denmark
are standing firm they want the rejected
asylum seekers out
the eu is not ready and does not have
the capacity to handle another major
migration crisis
while here in europe afghans already
make up around 10 of asylum seekers
they're the second largest group after
syrians
and for a continent still scarred by the
migration crisis of five six years ago
there is a feeling of deja vu a feeling
of having been there before that has
europeans worried they might be on the
verge of a fresh refugee crisis those
people who
are here from afghanistan they are not
migrant they are refugees and asylum
seekers
and that is why it is very important to
remember
that
all western countries have signed
human rights convention refugee
convention
and they are duty bound
to help anyone not only afghans but
syrians are anybody who come to the to
their country and ask for asylum because
of civil war in the country
are any conflict or personal uh threat
to to their life
so i think
when the western countries say oh we
don't care uh
if uh iran refugees go home or we deport
them i think this is
uh
a violation of human right and
we shouldn't do that kind of thing
you